markandrebecca Spencer are about to
learn the hard way
it was about five or six seconds of
sheer terror their dream house turns
into a nightmare
when they discover its horrific past
hearing all those voices just right
changed my life 13 o clock hey everybody
its episode 76 and guess who's back I'm
back yeah yeah I missed you so much
yeah so I go back to Mississippi you
know I mean they're like ma'am I never
leave this place is pretty cool and like
three days later I'm like oh yeah poor
Mississippi Mississippi's all right
yeah yeah it's nothing like Florida
though no no and looks like my dad's
pulled through he had a couple little
setbacks but looks like he made it so
it's pretty good they had they had to
keep him under for nearly seven days
that's going to be pretty freaky yeah
well he had a major heart attack the
night before the surgery right yeah that
cardio
I think it's called cardio graphic shock
cardiogenic shock I remember they are do
graphics shock which is his heart had
been starved of oxygen so they did the
quadruple bypass on him and they kept
him down for like seven days yeah cuz as
far as a week yeah because tom was gonna
come back almost a week before you
actually did come back but then after
that happened he's like well they're
gonna keep him under so I have to stay
here longer because you have been awake
so they kept him under for nearly a week
and then when he came to they put him in
recovery but his kidney started to fail
yeah because he had been asleep for so
long you know but anyway they put him
back on dialysis and eventually his
kidneys cotton came back so yeah so he I
think he's off dialysis now he's gonna
go into recovery but it could be
long-term you know he might be in there
for a month but he he'll make him a
piece tough and stubborn had to like tie
him down because he kept pulling off you
pull stuff out Oh his arms cuz he was
just going
72 years old Mississippi he was born
drinking bacon grease yes what could two
packs a day since he was 10 yeah all
right dude is lucky to be alive yeah and
yours as soon as he got home like he got
home we're recording this on Monday but
he got home on Friday night and he was
telling me all the stories about his dad
in the hospital you were just making me
laugh cuz you were doing your dad's
voice yeah and now he had um you know he
had this thing in his mouth so he was
having a hard time talking yeah so when
he wanted something he would just you
know make Latin yeah if the bed was up
he wanted to go down if it was down he
wanted to go up so yeah he got tired of
just saying raised me up and said
goodbye
yeah so you don't believe it yes Cowen's
you can't give you coca-cola and I said
they would give you cocoa you now I
don't believe it they don't believe in
the healing power coca-cola
no just fine he was a little bit out of
it and he started to go into uh what
they call recovery room psychosis which
is [ __ ] crazy yeah pull things out
yeah because he's you can't move I mean
he just had all that stuff yeah I gotta
get back to my truck
he's in Delhi all right now yeah so he's
yeah and he's gonna be in the hospital a
while longer but but they won't they
won't have all that stuff hooked up but
yeah he'll be he'll be in the regular
house I see okay let's start the show
all right so let's see so what's the
first thing we're gonna do I'm the main
part of the show since then people ask
what are you guys gonna do another
episode of a haunting so today we're
gonna do it today server rings can I do
a haunting yes okay I was gonna do it
last week but you know what I thought
you were coming back but you weren't
back so we didn't do it so how do you
think a lot of people love the home when
we do haunting episodes other people
don't get it because they didn't see ya
the episode that we're talking about
usually we're kind of like busting on
the show yeah pointing out stuff that
was cool that was funny
that's what we're gonna kind of do it a
little bit so straight because this is a
pretty interesting case well and this
too I like this one
times we can talk about the episode of a
haunting but this house the Allen house
is a very famous haunted house so it's
been on a bunch of different shows it's
had like a bunch of different paranormal
investigators there so there's a lot of
other information about it yeah and
there's a lot of documentation and the
claims aren't all that wild really
they're seeing apparitions and hearing
voices yeah and I should say too that
the episode of a haunting came out I
think in 2012 it was season five now
they also did the same story on
paranormal witness about a year later
but the paranormal witness episode had a
bunch of stuff that wasn't on the
episode of a haunting yes we want to
talk about it both so I kind of want to
talk about a bunch because I watched
both of them yesterday yeah and I was
watching this one I you know I don't
really have much experience with haunted
houses yeah
poltergeist yes I was in a bad house one
time but I never breathe you know and I
don't know maybe one day I'll get around
to telling that story I was in a bad
house one time with a friend of mine in
the Army we got out at the same time we
moved moved into it in Boston for
different reasons I had a girlfriend
there at the time and he he was moving
back he'd lived there before or you know
in the Boston area it was a bad house
and that's one way I can describe it bad
feelings bad dreams other people would
come in there and it had an eerie air to
it but I never could prove it yeah
nothing ever moves yeah nothing that
were really active just feel it well if
there are haunted houses which I'm not
gonna discount if there are haunted
houses this might be one of them yeah I
mean people have seen things in there
for a very long period of time even way
before like these people that were on
the show moved in because this house was
built nearly if there are haunted houses
this is probably what's there like and
like I said this is considered you know
most paranormal lists I looked at it one
of the top 10 most haunted houses in me
like that's it right it's an Arkansas by
the way it's kind of it's got screwed up
then I'm going well I believe
poltergeists not necessarily ghosts well
they're two different phenomena
different other things and I tend to be
naturally skeptical if I haven't seen it
myself I don't believe it although I say
that maybe there's a possibility yeah
I'm talking about yeah totally
disappears it certainly fair enough just
like I've never seen a Bigfoot
yeah I don't think there's any Bigfoot
in North North America but if there were
they'd be I'm Washington state maybe up
in Canada yeah if one was discovered
I go well yeah yeah plus it wouldn't be
a huge shot yeah right because it's just
an animal like I said a big animal yeah
all this stuff about spiritual Bigfoot
yeah that's just they're using those
tales to to explain away the lack of
evidence like well it doesn't leave
footprints because it's a spiritual
people plus they're kind of trying to
sexy you know yes to making it like
paranormal they know if there's a
Bigfoot it's a yeah it's just an animal
that's what I that's why I think that's
not one of the crazier than a hominid
yeah that's right
all right so for our news story like I
said I always try to do whether it's
like a true crime show or whether it's a
paranormal show I always try to find a
fairly recent news story that goes along
with one of those things yes yes so this
was the only one I found that was okay
we have an awesome thing we have
announcements to do though yes all right
so um as I usually do shout out my book
the faceless villain I actually recorded
an interview with the show mysterious
radio so I'll let you guys know when
that goes up but it's all about faceless
Ville and I talked about a couple of the
cases in there and you know shot the
[ __ ] about true crime in general yeah
faceless villain selling like hotcakes
same with unseen hand both of them are
running wild yeah both those books done
good and like I said I'm working on the
second volume of faceless villain which
will be from 1960 to 1980 unsolved
crimes and they're all the shit's in
their zodiac that went beyond this year
that will be out it'll actually probably
be out before summertime that's inertia
for June the latest hopefully I promise
you people I will be supervising the
production of the he's going to be
lurking no culture Jenny do the book do
the book we're gonna yeah so that'll be
out soon and also would like to give
shout outs to our we have two new
patrons yeah one of them is named James
and one of them is named Matthew all the
way from Brisbane in Australia yeah this
is guys if you're uh working on the line
in that kitchen right that's yes yeah I
talked to him on Facebook a lot yeah I
was a cook too yes
yeah I used to work in country clubs and
we got all of his co-workers in Darsh
yeah okay what's that we can do we
didn't Sam Sam special yeah so thank you
for that and I we also got a PayPal
donation from a person named Richard so
thank you very much um like I said you
know if you want to go to our patreon
page and give us a monthly donation or
you can go to our PayPal and give us a
one-time dinner you do whatever you want
you already you don't have to do
anything but it'd be nice if you did
something also our last movie review was
just me cuz Tom wasn't back yet it was
Suspiria so if you're into italian
horror go check that out if you haven't
already another they're not quite as fun
when you're not here
yeah well but you know that's just how
it rolls I did well I did Mulholland
Drive and I did Suspiria because I knew
that you haven't really seen those and
you weren't like super in town so I said
well well you're not here obviously well
I would only just be able to just do
comment so I guess I could watch well
yeah but they they wouldn't have been my
favorite movies unless they were somehow
become my favorite movie watching it on
the first time but usually favorite
movies tend to be like someone grew up
with although you know what we just got
a new copy the Blade Runner the new
blade a new blade and their title oh oh
my god that was a masterpiece man that
was so much better than the new Star
Wars I'm so mad at Disney outrageous but
positive note Blade Runner 2049 is yeah
excellent it made up for it some people
will gripe oh the movie was too long no
that's kids saying that that movie takes
its time ya know gonna buy which I got
you just takes its time I'm gonna tell
you a story and I'm gonna start right
here I'm just gonna let you see it yeah
the visuals are really good
the storytelling is good it's not a
typical Hollywood movie it's really not
you know nowadays but basically the
movies are made for 15 16 year-olds it's
just kind of like a Holly's blockbuster
one's a yacek holo spectacles now you
know but this one actually there's
something to it I thought yeah I really
yeah I like this one a lot alright so I
think that's all the regular show gonna
do oh yes so here's the only like
paranormal theme news story that I like
that was interesting that I could find
in last couple that came out in the last
week now this one was from the UK it
turned up it was in the Daily Mirror and
a couple of the other pay
over there which I guess are kind of sad
boys so this happened in Kent now
there's this fella named John wicks and
he has a twelve-year-old son named Harry
and evidently Harry is doing a project
for school about castles and how they're
built and stuff like that so he's like
okay well we're gonna go to Baines
furred Castle in Kent which is but it's
not like a you know it's ruins but you
know it's really beautiful there's
pictures of it all over the internet and
he said we're gonna go and we'll take
pictures of it for your project so
evidently the dad takes pictures of
innesford castle and he doesn't see
anything when he takes the pictures but
when he gets home later and looks at the
pictures there is a little figure in
there yeah this looks like a month looks
like a little ciao yeah it looks like
the figure of like a black monk yeah
which is interesting because actually in
my in my book that's in hand I talked
about a case I can't remember where it
was offhand but there there was another
haunting somewhere in England where they
kept seeing a black monk this thing I
don't know like must be like black monks
in England there seem to be a lot of
those for a black guy children may be
one person reports it and then someone
and then everybody else does its report
so okay so there are pictures and I will
put them in the YouTube video and you
can see them if you search like Amesbury
castle haunting or whatever yeah it's a
pretty recent story it just came out
like a week ago my first impression when
I looked at the picture I thought it
looked like a whole no what does it look
like a little artist like an entrance
but evidently he he says the guy that
took it he's like okay I didn't notice
anything when I took the picture there's
no doorway there and he contacted a
paranormal group or a paranormal
investigator who went to investigate
he's like yeah you're right there is no
door there you know there's no way it
doesn't look like a trick in the light
or anything likes pretty solid now John
says that in Kent there is a legend
about a black monk around that area so I
know this is according to him I couldn't
find a great deal of other information
about that but evidently there has been
a black monk seen in this area before
because the William
and spurred who was keeping track who
lived in the castle in like 11:30 like
later became a monk or left to become a
monk or something like that that's how
the story goes
so I guess there's kind of a legend
around the area of a monk but you know I
don't really know like I said I'll put
the pictures in there you can look at
him if you want to it does kind of look
it looks like a job when you blow it up
it looks like it has like the little
thing across the what you got yeah I'm
not an expert you know of course in
photography or photographic trickery I'm
not gonna make my own judgment on it and
want to leave that up to the audience to
do their own investigation I'm looking
at it and I'm thinking you know that
looks kind of like one of those little
pop-up man targets at a pistol it does
kind of look like that yeah yeah why
keep [ __ ] because it looks like a solid
thing it lets all of it looks kind of
flat and then it looks like maybe
somebody dragged a blanket over it
right dark blanket but I'm not saying
that that's what it is just saying
that's what yeah but you know worth
looking into I guess one of the funny
things that the guy said in the article
this John wicks guy he's like well I
don't know I'm kind of a skeptical about
paranormal stuff although he said that
he had had a near-death experience he
had a motorcycle accident similar to a
yeah and he died and was brought back to
life and he said when he died he saw his
grandfather yeah and his grandfather
told him he had to go back yes we're the
same kind of stuff so that's so you had
that a similar thing yeah it wasn't
grand although it was people you weren't
really sure yeah but bunch of people
that evidently I knew yeah my past lives
I guess yeah I kind of describe him to
you before what yeah yeah but I look
like a friend of ours oh yeah well yeah
but you know it was kind of like
prismatic light and the face was kind of
I could see the face look like a metal
Lord of the Rings slightly kind of
transracial kind of hood yeah like Elvis
yeah kinda inter but it would look like
human right you know I think they also
kind of look like some kind of girl and
a hood and she was sending me messages
but it was thought you know
yeah like telepathic yeah imagery and
stuff but the thing that made me laugh
at this
the thing that made me laugh this guy is
quoted in the article and he was like
talking about oh I was in the motorcycle
accident my cell my grandfather told me
to go back and then the next quote it's
on its own paragraph it might have been
because I was on a lot of morphine told
you that look like what was that girl's
name that we know Olivia Olivia yeah in
the back Olivia she's very ill yeah put
a picture of Olivia up there we'll get a
picture were like what we've used drawn
some of our posters yeah yeah she's a
little bitty thing that's right yeah
that's very funny but yeah I just I had
to mention that morphine because I study
so funny so yeah check the picture out
it's kind of interesting like I said I
thought it was a hole in the wall they
say it's not but who knows it looks like
a flat man target to me with a towel
throw them over or a blanket thrown over
yeah yes we're looking into you got it
you know all right so now we're gonna
talk about the episode of a haunting
that deals with the Allen house now
something that I found interesting and
when I was researching this just
something that kind of confused me
because on the Wikipedia page for a
haunting they have like an episode list
right yeah
now this episode is from season five and
on Wikipedia they haven't mentioned as
house of horrors yes you're telling me
look it's in season five no no I have
notice and then and then like I looked
it up and I looked on dailymotion they
had it on dailymotion and it's listed
under house of horrors but we have it's
not called the haunting of the yeah he's
already well you were gonna buy the one
and then I was like don't yeah yeah
looks like season seven is the last
season of the haunting that you can buy
on hard copy everything else is
streaming and it's up to 11 now
and I wouldn't you know I want to buy
the other seasons because we had we
don't have time to watch that when they
want to show it to us you know man we
never watch like regular we never
watched regular TV I wanted to get them
on DVD yeah they're good to have on what
time I got cussed out by somebody in the
comment section some girl deeply you
know buy DVDs we stream it you know some
16 year old girl
yeah I mean what cash is this I blocked
her yeah that awesome I don't like it
what a weird that mad a thing to get
upset about yeah man I like there are
these people certain angriff I don't
know way I see it you know when I have a
I you know I kind of have pride in
ownership in terms of like I have my own
DVD blu-ray collection it's like an
archive yeah so whenever I want to see
an episode I'll physically go over there
and grab it there's just something I
like about that yeah maybe it's a
generational thing maybe I kind of used
to be like that with music like I still
have a [ __ ] ton of CDs and stuff like
that but really the past few years I've
just been downloading everything or my
teens in check because it's I'm running
out of room seriously I got that Xbox
one so I just like to put stuff in it
yeah yeah
okay so so yeah I was super confused why
so it's called house of horrors when it
first aired in 2012 on the disc it's
called the haunting of the Allen house
but whatever it's the same episode yeah
yeah and it's one of the better episodes
for this season I really like this at
like the people seem pretty credit
incredible now they've like I said not
only were they on a haunting they've
also done they did a paranormal witness
episode they were on a segment of
haunted Arkansas which we also watched
it was about at five ten minutes I've
got a feeling that they did a haunting
first yeah I think they did I think
previous to a haunting they'd only been
on like local news shows after that it
was a haunting and then they did
paranormal witness about a year later
the guys written a book so you know he's
might be you wanted to sell the book you
know I try to sell my books today so I'm
not gonna
was on a haunting you know the audience
I don't know if they know that that was
almost on yeah they did they did call
and ask yeah but you know what's fun is
like the producer was like well you see
the thing is wrong destination America
what's the destination where it's not
destination yeah yeah there was this is
this isn't technically a ghost story so
and so I can't change the story yeah no
I want in there but it's not technically
it goes it doesn't go with their form
and I'm not gonna go along with what
they say yes I said no I'm not gonna do
it but that but they should have cuz it
would have been super creepy okay
actually paranormal witness but the
problem is is that actually my best
witness my uncle died yeah just a couple
months ago we go now
I mean Esther got Louis but Louis was
mostly just keeping Wesley under control
during the whole thing you know trying
everybody saw me and read they were the
ones that were just trying to figure
this thing out yeah just had to have
lost him at the age of 61 yeah it is
very sad but yeah so and I'd even get a
recording I ain't talking about it I
know damn well that's what you see I
have to like appreciate people one their
never know when they crow cawing crow
sometimes the way of the force yeah
alright so this episode house of horrors
haunting at the Allen house whatever
okay so we're gonna talk about the
haunting episode and then I'm going to
talk a little bit about the paranormal
witness one cuz the paranormal witness
one had a lot more good [ __ ] on it that
for some reason the haunting episode
didn't show yeah so it's pretty good
yeah I haven't seen any bit more recent
ones but okay so fireballs
you don't know what that means it is
don't season one yeah yeah all right so
the the house that we're talking about
the Allen house was actually built in
the early 1900s and it was known as a
haunted house previous to when this
family moved in that the show was about
but they claimed they did not know that
at the time because they were not from
Arkansas they were actually from
Oklahoma and the guy Mark Spencer he was
like a professor or a Dean or something
like that and he took a job at the
University of Arkansas as
Dean of Students for arts and humanities
or whatever and it was in Monticello
Arkansas now evidently his wife Rebecca
she was not super jazzed about moving to
Arkansas but when they were there kind
of when he went there for the interview
and he took his family and stuff like
that and they saw this house sitting on
this corner and she's like okay well I
will move here on the condition that you
buy me this house yeah now this it's not
just a house it's a mansion
it's eight thousand the square yes and
restoring a lot like many of the
episodes in a haunting the house in real
life looks a lot more impressive than
the one that they use yeah beautiful
yeah a real life house looks really good
and from what I've read on the internet
about this because the Spencer's who
were on the show they still live there
as far as I know and I've heard that
they have done wonders like with
renovating the place and stuff I mean
even from the outside and I've seen some
pictures of the interior it is gorgeous
yeah it looks really cool yeah so
evidently at the time that she saw the
house apparently it wasn't for sale so
they go to a realtor like they kind of
go up to the house I think the first
time mark goes up to the house and
knocks on the door and he thinks there's
no one home although he hears a radio
coming from the inside like playing some
kind of like creepy fire-and-brimstone
kind of holy role yeah like that
Southern Baptist and he said in that
kind of wigged amounts he's like man who
lives in theirs it's like listen to this
I want to do this or not and he said
that when they first went up to it it
was kind of not in terrible shape but
they said it needed like a lot of work
as it was the yard was real overgrown
and [ __ ] like that
so he's like there's no one home and
then he says to his wife you know I
don't know it's kind of in bad shape I
don't know if I want to do it or
anything like that and then they go to a
realtor and the realtor is like oh well
that house isn't for sale everyone knows
it's haunted you know it's very well
known in the area and he's like an the
woman that lives there would never sell
it anyway
so they kind of get bummed out and
everything like that and then later mark
starts doing research and discovers he's
like wow this is like one of the most
haunted houses in America and you know
starts reading about the history of it
and finds out about a woman that
committed suicide there
19:48 now at the time evidently nobody
knew why she had done it and I'll get
into that a little bit later because
they did actually find out and they says
now in the middle of researching this
house he suddenly gets a phone call from
the woman that lives there and says oh I
heard that you wanted to buy it you know
I'll have to meet you and your wife and
you know we'll come and hang out and
everything like that so he's like all
right so came in his wife go to the
house and he's like this really a really
nice old woman he's like now the outside
looked kind of you know needed work but
he's like the inside was really
beautiful and an interesting thing is
before they went and met the woman
they said they were walking by the house
one night and they looked up and they
saw a woman in the window like she was
sitting at a desk like writing a letter
or something like that and we're like oh
you know we let's keep going we don't
want people thinking that we're like
stuck in the house right but then when
they go and meet the old woman who lives
in the house and she gives them a tour
and she shows them the room where that
window would have opened from it's all
like junked up with furniture like and
there's no way that anybody could be
sitting at the window and the guy's like
oh well I saw you sitting in the window
the other night when we walk by and
she's like oh I haven't been here I've
been out of town and she's like a
nobody's been in this room for like 37
years we just pushed all this furniture
in here because no one uses you saw an
apparition at the would say they saw
something shop yes so that was the first
thing he saw and that was before they
even moved in okay now at this stage the
old woman is actually very friendly and
she's like you know she's like I never
really thought I would sell this house
cuz I love it and everything and she
said no it is haunted you know obviously
market or Becker like yeah we don't
believe in that stuff she's like oh but
yeah but she's like you know I think
that you guys are supposed to own it so
I'm gonna sell it to you yes I've got
that God had sent that yeah they were
the right kind of people to own the
house right so they thought it was some
kind of kismet just because like I said
when Rebecca first got to Arkansas she
saw that house she's like I want that
house yeah you know what I mean so they
thought it was some kind of destiny or
fate that they were supposed to end up
there yeah so they eventually end up
buying the house now on the haunting
episode they have a bunch of kids I
think three but they never really went
into that they interviewed one of the
the daughters on paranormal witness but
they didn't have any of the kids on
there but apparently some of the kids
saw some [ __ ] too but I'll get into that
later
so the first thing
happens on the episode of a haunting the
first thing that's creepy because really
the first 10 15 minutes of it are the
whole before they even move into the
house rough so they move in and they
start working on it renovating it now
the first thing is that mark goes up to
the attic to get something or other
because they're working on the house and
he says he feels like he's being watched
yeah like very very strongly yeah and I
remember this scene it kind of reminds
me of not only the poltergeist
experience I went to that feeling of
being Watchers I don't know how I don't
know how he meant being feels like
they're being watched I mean yeah what
mechanism does this I don't know some
people said that there might be some
kind of a quantum effect going on that
yeah that you can predict earlier that
there's a statistical thing that you can
use to find out when somebody feels like
they're being watched yeah like one time
I saw a program about the security
business and they were teaching security
guards who watched cameras you know
watching for shoplifters and the guys
that were running the program saying
don't watch too closely or the person
that you're looking at on the camera can
feel it like they're being watched and
evidently there's like some statistical
data that can back this up well they
have done lab tests where people most of
the time people can tell they're being
looked at it's weird
which is yeah which is pretty freaky you
must say something do with quantum
physics so in some ways if a ghost is
looking at you the quantum effect
happens and you can feel it yeah maybe I
mean I felt it I felt it during the
phase yes so I and then at that weird at
that bad house that I've talked about
earlier yeah everybody kind of had that
feeling of being watched like someone's
watch and you could kind of feel from
what direction you were being looked at
yeah but there was nothing there yeah it
was weird
and that's the same thing it seemed like
this the same thing because I've seen
several shows that this guy is on so I
could kind of you know get a picture of
what happened in the house and yeah he
said in the Attic you felt very strongly
as that you were being watched not
necessarily malevolent he's like he just
felt like you were being watched now he
said on the floor he found a photograph
of a baby like you can only see its arm
and he looked on the back and there's a
name on the back of it with the Miss
Liddell
I don't know I think they knew that that
was the name of the woman that had
committed suicide the house things like
why would anybody work the picture maybe
and a half yeah he was a little weirded
out and then he said that he glad
stopped and saw a shadow on the wall
yeah and at first he thought it was his
shadow he's like oh that's interesting
you know that like and then he starts
moving his hand and the chef doesn't
move and they shine and flashlights on
it to try to get that play of light yeah
the shadow is consistent it just stays
there like a shadow of a person in the
episode of the haunting he actually
casts the beam of the flashlight on to
the shadow itself and it doesn't
dissipate yeah it lightens a little bit
but it the shadow does not totally go
away yeah which that's not possible
right that's just not possible
but that's the show now here's the thing
they don't show him saying that he did
that they just show his character doing
that yeah so we don't know if that's
what he told no opting yeah that's just
what the haunt the game
the haunting wanted to play well witness
had this incident it actually had it
happened at a different time in the
timeline and it was similar but a little
bit different how was it portrayed then
it was actually portrayed as if he had
seen it on the floor okay but I think he
did say on paranormal witness that he
saw this shadow on the floor and he
thought it was his and it didn't he
shine the flashlight on it
I don't you didn't really say that okay
maybe you show that no I'm not that I
remember
okay but it was on the floor and [ __ ]
like that sir probably a good time to
take a break okay so we're gonna take a
break right now we'll come back we'll
talk about the rest of the haunting
episode then I want to get into some of
the stuff that was on paranormal witness
and what the differences were and stuff
like that so we will be back in just a
few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back talking about a haunting
the haunting at the Allen house yeah
okay so the next thing that happens on a
haunting was that the wife Rebecca she's
home by herself one day and she hears
very clearly she says someone walking
around in the Attic she said it was very
heavy footfalls very obviously footfalls
now the thing was even though she and
Mark at this point knew that the house
was known for being honored she did not
presume that it was a go she thought it
was a person yeah that had broken into
the house now the woman that owned the
house before them when she was getting
ready to sell this house to the new
couple she's saying she's telling them
oh I hear talking all the time of the
ghosts are talking I had the house
exorcise it's not as strong as it used
to be yeah and the husband's like yeah
okay he was just trying to be polite he
didn't believe that it was real yeah no
they're starting to see things and hear
footsteps yeah so she hears footsteps
now she thinks it's a person so
basically she runs down the hall closes
the attic door drams a chair up against
it okay and then she calls the husband
and she's like hey somebody's in the
house but when they go up there
investigate there's no one up there and
this is another very common thing they
always hear footsteps the Attic seems to
be the focal point of the disturbances
yeah now at this up to this stage
because the Allen house was so popular
in the neighborhood and I guess it kind
of got around that some new people had
bought it they're like we would just get
random-ass people come into the house
wanting to come inside this it's like
the famous haunted house right and
Rebecca at first is just like you know I
don't want all these like strangers like
especially teenagers and of like
trooping around my house we live here
again I reckon but then you know she's
like we were doing all the renovations
it was really expensive I mean it's a
giant house yeah and then they were like
okay well Halloween's coming up why
don't we open the house up for Halloween
and like charge people five bucks and
give them a tour and stuff like that
yeah based on the data they score
three grand there first yeah because I
mean mark Spencer's on there saying yeah
I thought maybe fifty people would show
up he's like six hundred people share it
up to tour the house now they had hired
a couple local students to come and give
a tour through the house so during one
of the tour groups yeah they have one of
the students there they interviewed him
on the show the one that did this
particular tour group now he's in the
bedroom where Liddell killed herself and
he's kind of telling the people the
story and all of a sudden evidently yeah
the closet door flies open and a shirt
flies out of it yeah it's pretty cool
that's pretty cool moment in the
haunting episode when that shirt goes
out but I watch that happen and I was
going blast sound so that's a lot of
like poltergeist yeah yeah and like I
said even though the episode of a
haunting focused a lot more on the
apparitions and the finding out of the
history about the house and stuff the
paranormal witness one had a lot more
like poltergeist type activity that they
didn't really go into an effective
typically hauntings don't involve moving
movement of objects
yes apparitions but there was more of
that yeah then they said so that's a I
guess you could probably say they're
kind of an unusually strong ghost if
that's what you want to wallet kind of a
strong haunted one that can actually
move objects yeah yeah so evidently this
shirt flies out of the closet yeah now
one of the guys on the tour he's like oh
you guys rigged it good trick and all
this other stuff and then the student is
like no we didn't do that go check so
the guy goes and looks in the closet
there's no no no strings read now
evidently one of the older women that
was on the tour to now she said that she
saw a spirit that it was Liddell cuz
it's like a woman that I remember fairy
clothing yeah she still hung up at the
top of the stairs I think yeah or she or
she was leaving the room and she turned
around and saw her and she's gone thank
you so much you know what she said at
first but then when she talked to mark
when she was leaving she's like thank
you so much for opening your house I saw
her and she was all excited about it she
said I would never forget that as long
as I live so apparently that was a cool
experience for her now the next thing
that happened the next paranormal thing
that happened on the episode now they
show Rebecca and she's in the living
room
vacuuming now they show they had an
old-timey record player of Victrola one
of the ones that you have to crank to
get it to work and evidently while she's
vacuuming she hears a record on there
start to play and she's like now no
one's been in this room you have to
crank it to get it to go so she goes
over there and she picks up the needle
and puts the needle back down and the
record just stops she's like now that
shouldn't happen because if someone had
cranked it it was to have enough pain
then it would still have enough energy
it was just wide down she's like but it
didn't do that it just stopped all of a
sudden yeah now on some other things
that I've seen her on and she and I
noticed too on the haunting episode she
never said she heard music playing right
beside she saw it spinning and she said
it spun faster and faster longer the
longer you looked at it yeah now on
paranormal witness also marks daughter
Bronte was also in the room and saw it
also yeah so yeah they didn't share that
on a haunting they just showed Rebecca
in there by herself but she yes so she
puts the needle back - it stops all of
sudden she's like wow that's really
weird then she goes upstairs to tell
mark about it and while she's in the
hallway she also sees the ghost right of
Ladell so she says how is she describing
it was weird because she kind of like on
the later shows she actually saw some
other apparitions - not just her but she
said she saw the woman and she said four
five or six seconds she saw her and she
said that on the show it almost looked
like it jumped for an attacked her I
don't she didn't really get that
impression she said it was terrifying
but she didn't know that's a scene where
it's standing there and then when it's
out at her and she crumbles in the into
the ground which like she's hurt right
but she didn't really say it that way
she said it was terrifying but she more
got the idea that the ghost was trying
to tell her something or was trying to
get her attention not that she was
trying to attack her or anything
necessarily so yeah that was the next
thing that happened there and then they
decide they're gonna call a paranormal
group to come investigate finally after
all these people have seen this stuff so
they call this group called Louisiana
spirits and it's led by this woman named
best Maxwell now they come to the house
and Mark and Rebecca are gonna go
you know they send the kids to friends
houses they said okay we're gonna go out
now Rebecca says before we even went out
and left the paranormal team there
we felt like we shouldn't go like I had
this really bad feeling now while
they're getting ready to leave Mark said
he started feeling really weird they
show him like walking down the stairs
and he like stumbles and Stephanie said
he just felt really dizzy and really
strange and he's like the energy like
it's really weird like oppressive kind
of energy almost like it was telling
them not to go but they did go so they
leave the paranormal team there on the
show it's best Maxwell and it was like
two other women so they're starting to
set up all their equipment and then
there were a couple things on a haunting
they they sort of put together like all
of it because this team I think actually
came back two or three times okay
because this first investigation had to
be abandoned because what ended up
happening best is up in the attic and
she has her little EMF meter and her EMF
meter goes haywire and then she hears a
voice saying
Ladell like she hears a woman's voice so
she hears that in the Attic meanwhile
there's another woman down in the
parlour or something like that it looks
like and she's setting up a camera and
she hears a woman singing like a record
okay now right after that happened they
said they were just getting ready to
start the investigation turn on the
recorders on and stuff like that all of
a sudden there's a huge flash things
that look like lightning outside the
house I remember as far yeah and all of
the power went out except for the audio
recorders the other recorders are still
on but everything else went out one of
them says oh well I saw sparks it was
probably a transformer but they look out
the window and all the neighbors still
have power across the street next door
everybody still has power everybody but
them so they call mark and Rebecca who
haven't gone that far they're only just
right down the block or whatever because
they just left and they and said to come
back to the house you gotta see this so
they come back now they go out to the
backyard and it turns out that this
really big leafy branch run has come off
the tree and pulled the power cord out
of the yeah the power line outside
house right which could be a coincidence
I don't know mark is like I don't know
this is a healthy tree that it wasn't
storming it was like a total yeah was a
healthy limb that proves a healthy live
like a big healthy limb yeah and the
woman who was leading in the paranormal
investigations she said that she didn't
believe in coincidences yes she said she
was such a weasel like this odd that as
soon as we were gonna start the
investigation that should happened and
we had to leave because all the power
was out right now later on I guess like
I said since the audio recorders were
still going they did get some EVPs the
first time and they did get some later I
don't think they played any on that show
there's some on YouTube that people of
God they're not super impressive so she
plays best maxval plays the EVP that she
got she got like 40 she says okay but
the one they played on the show it's not
the real one but when the PERT when the
investigator said oh it must be a
transformer there's a woman's voice
saying not a transformer yeah so best is
like freaking out cuz she's like well
this is like an intelligent haunting
it's like talking that was more than one
voice actually it's one thing that don't
like about a haunting episodes they
never actually they never the evidence
yeah they never show you this the axe
parent all the witness will sometimes
yeah but not well that's the whole point
of paranormal witness they're going to
show usually what's happening at this
point is that in this case what's a
paranormal investigators show up you're
mostly getting the EVPs yeah that's
basically what you're getting which is
not quite as impressive as the people
actually seeing apparitions well you
know that's just how it's how the case
goes I guess it's easier to get an EVP
than it is to see an apparition
apparitions are more rare but evidently
like I said a lot of people have seen
apparitions in this particular on yeah
so the next thing that happens and this
is kind of getting toward the end of the
episode mark says that it's a Saturday
morning he suddenly wakes up with a
compulsion that he has to go up to the
attic he doesn't know why or anything
like that so he's like well okay I so I
go up to the attic and the way they show
it on the show was that he goes up there
and he has like a weird feeling and and
then there's like a light shining from
like behind these wall panels or yeah
and he pulls them off and he finds a big
envelope that has a bunch
letters in it right and he takes all the
letters out and he reads them all and I
think it in one program I saw he
actually found them in the floorboards
and actually I seen floral I've seen
photos of the actual thing that he took
it was the floor okay it wasn't behind a
wall and actually paranormal witness got
that right they showed it on the floor
but on a haunting it's close enough
whatever wall floor so he pulls the
board's out and there's all these
letters in there and there's 82 letters
they are all addressed to Liddell Alan
Bonner turns out that they are love
letters from a man named Princess Savage
who lived in Minneapolis yeah now
apparently these two had dated when they
were teenagers but then he moved away
then they married other people now
Ladell she actually she had a son but
she ended up getting divorced her
husband's name is Boyd I think she got
divorced in 1979 I want to say and
Prentiss Savage he married someone else
to I don't know his wife's name was he
was like the vice president of Texaco he
was like some big muckety-muck yeah
Texaco oil was pretty big back then yeah
but he evidently came back to Arkansas
and him and Liddell started an affair
right even though he was still married
she wasn't she was divorced and in these
letters it seems that he's saying he's
gonna leave his wife and we're gonna be
together forever as long as wha and she
was like all happy about it these are
the letters spanned you know like seven
months like the seven months before she
died but after around October of 1948
the letters started getting more distant
he started saying stuff like he doesn't
think he's gonna be able to leave his
wife it's gonna be a big scandal he
can't take it bla bla bla but in the
letters he did say that they would be
together at Christmastime so evidently
what happened they're thinking because
like I said nobody knew while adele had
killed herself she drank mercury cyanide
on Christmas night damn she actually
didn't die right away she was in a coma
for about a weekend then she died later
on so what they think happened is that
her mom would always have a big
Christmas party at Allen house so
evidently Liddell was at this party and
she was waiting because she thought that
Prentiss would show up and he didn't
show up
Rochester so she
Bentley went up in her room she got a
cup of punch yeah
put mercury cyanide in it and drank it
yeah and just laid down in her bed and
done so Mark Spencer and Rebecca Spencer
are very convinced and they say like I
said that they were skeptics before this
but they are convinced that Liddell
wanted them to find these letters
they're like because we wouldn't have
found them otherwise they were hidden
they were like under a floorboard he
thinks that she wanted everybody to know
why she had done it because nobody knew
for a long time so he actually later
ended up writing a book called a haunted
love story and it was all about her now
the interesting thing and I'm gonna go a
little bit into the paranormal witness
episode and then you know maybe a little
bit into the history of the house like
what some other people have seen there
something I found interesting on the
paranormal witness episode like I said
there was a lot more poltergeist type
activity okay and they also interviewed
marks daughter Bronte who they didn't
interview on this they didn't really get
any of the kids I saw I saw some of the
stuff there so the haunting episode I
saw a few things online but not seeing
the paranormal yeah you did see it but
we saw it like a long time a long time
ago I don't remember if I watched it
yesterday okay so it's pretty fresh in
which what do you think was better I
like the paranormal witness one better
okay it's just because it seems more
substantive okay on the paranormal
witness they take out that whole part at
the beginning with the old woman and
selling them the house and everything
like really in paranormal witness they
get to Arkansas they see the house it
has a for sale sign in the front and
they just buy it there's no thing about
that woman living there I'm selling it's
their work like that so none of that is
there another thing that they put in the
paranormal witness episode and this was
actually kind of interesting so
evidently Rebecca is out working in the
yard she's got her little headphones on
or whatever and the dad and the two sons
are messing around out in the yard with
their metal detector he's except
something we did as a hobby you know now
they find the metal detector goes off
and they dig in there and they find a
penny from 1948 a pillbox and a lipstick
case now as soon as they find this
Rebecca says that she's listened to her
headphones
she's like the music cut out and then
someone like a voice came over her
headphones
saying her name
and then she looked up at the house and
saw a woman in the upstairs window in
the bedroom where Ladell committed
suicide and she like looked and she saw
it right and then the music came back on
all of a sudden but she said the vizac
cut out and she heard someone say
Rebecca very clearly into her headphones
okay so that was something they didn't
put on a haunting now there was some
other [ __ ] too with other witnesses and
they didn't do any of this on our own
thing either
okay so Rebecca hasn't been into stuff
happened after the haunting episode was
oh there wasn't much really just edited
yeah they maybe just edit it out there
wasn't much time in between women she
was only like less than a year apart
really all right
so Rebecca had a friend named destiny
and Rebecca and Mark were having a yard
sale and destiny was bringing some stuff
over so she could sell some of the yard
sale now destiny she saw someone in the
upstairs window now she thought it was
Rebecca she said it looked like Rebecca
but then she comes to the door Rebecca
is at the door so she's like I just saw
you in the upstairs which is like I've
been upstairs what are you talking about
then she's carrying her stuff into the
house and she sees a woman standing in
the parlor or the library or something
like that and she thought that was
Rebecca and she said hey why don't you
come help me like get the boxes out of
the car and she says and Rebecca who she
thought it was just ignore her and she
was like BAM [ __ ] whatever you know it
was kind of the implication to said that
[ __ ] get your lazy ass out here
but yeah so she thought it was Rebecca
and then the woman like turned toward
her and her face was kind of all messed
up but the interesting thing is that and
I've seen some other stuff about this
house that I've been on other sites
saying yeah they saw doppelgangers
people saw someone they thought was
Rebecca but it was but it wasn't now I
said her face messed up what exactly
they talked well on the show they showed
like half of her face like it was cut
and kind of rotted okay I don't know if
the girl actually saw that I don't think
she said that specifically but she said
when the woman turned to workers she saw
that it wasn't Rebecca I think one of
the weirdest stories about this house
saved her what was the husband's name
again I forgot
mark mark sees a woman staring out the
window but the shades are closed just
like a person's with their face stored
in the shade like looking at the
curtains looking at the curtains yeah he
walks up to it he said that's a ghost
yeah walks up to him got about
hello miss something like that well he
thought it was his wife Oh II did oh
yeah that's how I remembered it all
right and he goes hello hello and he
expected her to turn around but she
didn't she just vanished when he got
about three feet from her yeah he
thought it was his wife and I should
note on a haunting - that when he was
reading the letters up in the attic he
says he looked up and he saw a woman and
that they knew what Ladell looked like
because they'd seen a picture of her and
he said I saw a woman that looked like
Ladell and she was standing there
looking at me he's like but then when I
looked at it again it was Rebecca it was
his wife now there was another thing he
just kind of described it better because
like I said they were on haunted
Arkansas like on a section of it and he
was on there talking and he kind of went
a little bit more into that he actually
said that
Ladell the ghost of Ladell walked to
warn him and he saw her very clearly but
then he's like then I looked again and
she was back by the door and it was
Rebecca right you know what I mean so he
didn't really say that on haunting but
he said that on haunted Arkansas so he
kind of specified over over the years so
you know I've run into this many cases
where there's doppelgangers or ghosts or
poltergeists that could mimic some
family members voice they do hear from
you know we call him from across the
house yeah what'd he call before I
didn't call you yes but this was yeah
this was something that in phenomenon
yeah mark said that he saw Ladell and
Rebecca kind of morphing into one
another and her friend destiny said she
definitely saw some of this she thought
was her breakfast it looked like Rebecca
but it couldn't have been Rebecca
because Rebecca wasn't in that part of
the house or whatever now there were a
couple other things that were on
paranormal winces out here's another
thing that was kind of like more
poltergeist activity mark said for one
week straight every morning when he came
down to the kitchen to make coffee or
whatever there would be a broken glass
on the counter Wow okay and the cabinet
was always closed nothing else was
disturbed yeah but there would always be
a glass broken on there
yeah it was like the same one over and
over again soon no yeah it was the same
type of glass he's like they showed on
the show
they said we had just all these glasses
like an arroyo in your cabinet cabinet
door was closed that's next time a
poltergeist for D yeah so it was always
broken now on the show I he didn't
really say that specifically but the
show made the Association maybe that was
the cabinet that had the punch glass
that Liddell took out to put the punch
in that she killed herself but you know
he didn't make that Association cheryan
too much into yeah they might but he
said yet for a week we found a broken
glass on the counter every single
morning
the daughter Bronte she also reported
hearing footsteps walking around outside
her room and the sound of ice clinking
in a glass okay when no one was out
there that iced tea yeah also she said
the fan in her room she watched it she's
like it started to speed up and then she
saw there were buttons on the post of it
yeah and she said she saw them going in
and out like pushing in anyway and she's
like finally it speeded up so much that
it kind of blew up or it sparked out and
they didn't put that on the show now
there was another friend who was
interviewed on paranormal witness her
name was Regan and she was actually
house-sitting for them watching their
animals and stuff like that while they
were on vacation and she went up to the
attic because Rebecca called her and
said it was storming and she's like can
you go up there and make sure because we
have buckets the roofs leaking and stuff
just make sure the buckets haven't
overflowed so she goes up to the attic
and while she's up there the door she
puts a chair underneath the door like so
it doesn't close are you so it doesn't
close on her but while she's in there
the door closes on her and she's wigging
out loca freaking out she goes back down
and the door is closed and the chair is
down the hall
as if someone has picked it up and flung
it but she didn't hear anything
no okay not no not that I but she
freaked out she's like alright [ __ ] that
and she was she's like I'm out of here
so she kind of ran away from the house
also another thing they didn't mention
on haunting was that the paranormal
investigators before the power went out
on their first investigation they said
they actually sell smelled cigar smoke
okay Rebecca also reported smelling
cigar smoke there have been several
other paranormal investigative teams in
there and they've also reported the same
thing they actually say that
Ladell is not the only spirit that's
there
that there's actually six and people
have seen apparitions of children also
now on paranormal witness
Rebecca said that she saw an apparition
of a man in a cowboy hat on the stairs
and this was right around the time
because like I said they changed the
timeline on paranormal witness around a
little bit what they had happened here
was that mark was up in the attic
finding the letters and he found the
letters because of the shadow on the
floor they didn't share that on a
haunting they showed that it's like the
first thing that happened but paranormal
witness
they showed he there was a shadow on the
floorboard and he pulled up the floor
Brunner that's where the letters were
meanwhile Rebecca was downstairs and
sees an apparition of a man and she said
it was very scary with a cowboy hat
so people have seen other apparitions
other than LaBelle yeah I'm just gonna
say this go so rare if there are host
ghosts are very rare so that means
finding one of them is difficult yes six
of them no I don't believe it
yeah but that's I'm just saying boys
notice that the more paranormal
investigators you bring onto a case the
more the number of ghosts increases I
believe there's something to this
haunting I don't have that I don't
really like to see it myself you know I
think there's something to this case
guarantee is just one ghost if there's a
ghost it's just one because that goes
could mimic and manifest itself any way
it wants to it does seem like most of
the stuff that's been her because here's
the thing princess you're the god to
happen yes how do you know that wasn't
Liddell's boyfriend no well that's what
they implied yeah maybe the ghost of
Liddell is thinking about the boyfriend
yeah the boys that's what they images
she had seen she said she didn't say it
was like malevolent she said it was
scary-looking seems like a shock figure
yeah and a couple other people are
reported seeing little kids or hearing
little kids voices like on EVP now any
know that that's not the imaginary
offspring of her she's imagining his
ghost yeah she's a ghost in the
afterworld imagine and having kids with
the guy and those are just and those are
just the
dreamchip goes yeah yeah load the dream
up ghost's yeah seems like that like I
said the house was built in 1906 by the
Allen family that's why it's called the
Allen house Liddell was one of Joe
Allen's daughters the middle daughter
that was the guy that built the house it
was actually in the Allen family for a
very long time in the 50s late 50s I
think it was 1959 it was still owned by
the Allen family but they section it off
in two apartments so there were actually
a lot of renters that live there and
over the years many renters have seen
apparitions
I heard footsteps that's pretty much the
most common thing smelled cigar smoke
stuff like that and pretty much I think
in the 80s it was converted back into a
private residence and then there were a
couple residents and then the Spencer's
bought it in 2007 and as far as I know
they still live there and as I said from
what our from other paranormal sites
that I've looked at everything they said
they've done a beautiful job or story I
mean the outside of it for real it's a
gorgeous gorgeous house it's enormous
now they do do tours they do a big thing
on Halloween they've been doing that
every year they do tours but you have to
get an appointment obviously because
they live there I'm sure they don't want
people tripping through their house at
all hours but you can still do it and
it's been investigated by taps it's been
in but it was actually there was an
episode of ghost hunters
send in there I haven't seen it ghost
brothers they went there but you know
there's been tons of other
investigations about it and it's been on
the local news everything like it's a
very famous haunted house I'm like I
said Mark Spencer wrote a book about it
wasn't so much about the haunting per se
I think it was mostly about Liddell and
her history and how he discovered the
letters so might be a good book it might
be yeah a show in Myra he seems like a
nice dude I mean that seems like a nice
family it really does so you know what
whether it's true or not I don't know
I've never been there I guess if you're
interested in the case I'd recommend
getting that book yeah yeah and like I
said paranormal witness a hard thing
they both did it
mmm like I said I didn't see the ghost
hunters who don't usually watch that but
but they went there to I don't know if
they really captured anything and
actually if you search Allen house on
YouTube it got like ghost brothers
feather better than ghost ghost brothers
is very and they say police ghost
brothers is hilarious it's very
interesting well they're very aware of
how funny they are and how funny the
whole situation
so it's a little tongue-in-cheek they're
kind of serious but it's still kind of -
yeah I recommend goes I really do like
this brothers very funny yeah oh yeah
okay so Wow we just we went on rounds in
there
yeah so I guess we're getting to the
show I hope you guys enjoyed this
there's another paranormal extravaganza
yeah it was good to be back on the show
I know it's you so much oh I did I'm
Kenny also miss Dianna that's why I came
back in that cab that kind of sitting on
the back of the couch is a song it was
like what and just was started looking
back and forth between you and my mom
who is that yeah she was like she you
can see the whites of her eyes yeah and
then she would call chase me
she runs up in her she likes to go up
and her in the top of her tree and yeah
put if you poke the outside of the
little with Kentrell apartments they're
like little apartments that glow yeah
you poked the outside so she can like
clawed it she loved that's like her game
she won't play that and throwing her
little chicken yeah then Tim misleaders
because I remember this guy yeah I
remember yeah he does this for me he
does that for me he throws my chicken
yeah I gotta get video for throwing that
that toy to you guys I don't know like
I've had a lot of cats throughout my
life but I've never seen one that could
throw her own toys one-handed one-handed
like she grabbed it and she ranches like
a puppy yeah she's probably about six
months old now man yes she will pick up
she has like this chicken like a little
stuffed chicken that's one of her
favorite things to tear up and she will
pick it up in one pot and sling it
laughs are and she stands up to throw it
yeah she'll stand up as she figures if
daddy's not here to throw it I'm gonna
throw it yeah Jen awesome it's very
funny yeah she's a very as you can catch
do it yes right Andrew canty and [ __ ]
and then she'll bring it back up on the
bed like already good yeah yeah she's
very funny dog yeah she's very and well
she has she had her little tail was a
bit off by a dog when she was a baby
yeah before we got her this is the room
she doesn't remember it so she only has
like a little stump of a tail yes mr.
Ian's is long and so she's just like
wags it she's always like
it's the funniest thing you've ever seen
but anyway so okay that'll be that's the
end of the show hope you guys enjoyed it
you know very happy that tom is back
remember if you are into true crime or
anything please check out my book
faceless villain if you've read the
faceless villain and you haven't left a
review please do that because you can
ask yeah if you like that book and like
I said vol 2 will be out probably before
summer I'm working on it very hard I
promise
also if you'd like to support the show
don't forget to go check out our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
the so then you can go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation you may do so also
check out our latest movie review
actually are it's just my review of
Suspiria that came out on Friday if you
haven't checked it out we will be doing
another movie review probably this
Friday I don't know what movie we're
doing yet though but it'll be something
good I promise and that'll do it for
episode 76 see you next Tuesday bye
it's too bad
you push your own numbers
and let your house ring till I wake up
girls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]